right
hello everyone
welcome to our midday briefing
live on ebs we are today friday the 4th
of february
senegal
union africans
for participating
ocean summit
organizing presidency
to continue let me call stefan who has
important news on trade with the us
and our eu health standards
stefan
good afternoon everybody i have today on
this beautiful friday good news for the
fans of mussels and other shellfish
i'm actually glad to announce that as
from the end of this month
trade of so-called bivalve mollusks and
i'm talking here about mussels oysters
scallops and clams will be possible
again between the united states and
european union
more precisely spain and the netherlands
will be allowed to export their bivalve
mollusks to the united states
whilst massachusetts and washington
state will be allowed to do the same to
the european union
after years of discussions and audits
between the united states and the
commission
both sides decided today indeed to
reopen their transcend transatlantic
cooperation
on for these products
a significant and important element of
this important step forward is the fact
that other eu member states
could also be allowed to export their
bivalve mollusks to the united states
on the base of a simplified
authorizing authorization procedure
agreed between the united states and
european union
if you want to know more about mussels
oysters clams and scallops consult a
good cooking book but first check out
our press corner thank you
thank you stefan you're making me really
hungry here so i called on all
journalists to have pity on us and allow
us to go to lunch afterwards
um
and i'm absolutely not biased when it
comes to the origin of the bivalve most
that you were talking about as long as
they taste good
okay
[Music]
is
yes now you can hear me i guess
eric
as you've mentioned the visit of the
polish president in town on monday do
you envisage any press statements either
oral or written or press conferences and
how about the exact timing so this is
the question on logistics and i have
also some questions on energy so i'll
keep it for team later
thanks no i can't provide you with uh
details on the logistics uh for the for
the moment i'll need to check the exact
timing to be honest uh
i did not check before uh before coming
down and when it comes to
any statements we will have uh we will
have to see
okay well listen um
since this was a very short question
beater i'll give you the floor on energy
um so now on energy to questions um
first on the ruling of the of the court
uh two days ago they decided to annul
the decision of the commission to reject
the complaint by the polish wholesaler
pgnig which is in public speak
paganinique
alleging the abusive practices by
gastrum with the commission appeal or if
not
when will the commission start the
investigation
and the second question if i may also on
energy
it concerns the um not zoom 2 and the
new german-based subsidiary
operator set up by gas from 454
kilometer pipeline
um
will the commission consider it as a uh
something that can be independent or the
commission has some doubts and does it
mean
with this new subsidiary that the whole
process of certification shall start
from the beginning thank you
thank you very much on the second
question and i'm looking at tim
to make sure that i say the right thing
but at the moment as you know the
procedure is at the level of the
national authorities uh so obviously uh
for the moment the commission will
refrain from any from making any comment
on um
on this procedure or on the underlying
facts on your first question it's
actually a competition question so for
ariana ayana you have the floor thank
you very much indeed on wednesday the
court has delivered two judgments
relating to gasper
in the first judgement we have taken
note that the general court has
dismissed
pgng's application for annulment of a
2018 commission decision against
gansprom
in its in our decision we had imposed
legally binding commitments on gastrum
to address the competition concerns that
we had identified in the context of an
investigation into gas problems
practices in central and eastern
european gas markets
in the second judgment
well we have taken note also of that one
of course and the court had upheld
instead uh pg e nig's application for
annulment of a 2019 commission decision
rejecting pg
and ig's a complaint against gazprom's
alleged anti-competitive practices
always in central and um eastern
european gas markets we will carefully
study the judgment and reflect on
possible next steps so i'm afraid that
at this stage i cannot go further than
this
okay i see lots of hands raised in the
in the chat um i assume that they're not
all on the issue of energy that we are
and competition that we are currently
discussing please only keep your hand
raised if your question
is
on
energy
beater you have a follow-up
no
no no thank you okay very good
tanya
is it on this
hello
hello
okay we're not uh
managing to connect so we will consider
that this issue is closed and you have
the thought yeah
thanks angelima
angelo remember for mansa it's about
food and trade again um if you could
give us at the set of the play
of the
trade disruption on black olives from
spain its eu us
situation as well
the eu
won a wto panel and
what's the signal play
you really want to make us hungry today
a question for miam i believe
thank you very much so what we can say
is that we welcome that the u.s has
accepted the final part and report in
the ripe
olives case by the dispute settlement
body of the world trade organization we
are now waiting and expect the us to
safely take the appropriate steps
to bring itself in compliance with the
finance recommendations and this will
end this dispute
that was causing of course a bit of
distress in our trade relationship so we
are very much welcoming this development
all right any other questions
on this issue
no on other trade related matters for
miriam
neither okay so i give the floor to
mumshil who had raised his hand
previously mom shall you have the floor
obvious that's angelina piscova
from bulgarian national radio sorry for
this confusion
but okay
[Music]
so
um
[Music]
a
october
i have a question for peter if possible
just ask a question what is the reaction
of the commission in the higher
representative to the closing
of
the deutsche welle studio in moscow by
russia
yes thank you very much peter
good afternoon thank you for the
question unfortunately this is really
bad news and bad development this
decision by russian authorities is
unacceptable and lacks any justification
the russian authorities linked their
decision or justified their decision by
the decision of a german regulator to
ban the russian state broadcaster rt
deutschland from operating in germany
due to the absence of a valid license so
this decision is completely unrelated to
the work of deutsche welle in russia and
this reaction by russian authorities
regrettably illustrates yet again their
continuous violation of media freedom
and disregard for independence of media
we stand in the solidarity with deutsche
welle and it's uh personal in russia and
we will continue to follow the situation
very closely we expect that deutsche
bala will have full and fair access to
all legal steps in order to challenge
this unjustified decision in russia and
we will also issue a corresponding
statement on this issue
thank you very much uh so this opens the
foreign relations uh chapter of this
midday briefing first are there any
other questions
on uh this um closure of deutsche welle
by the russian authorities
um i see one hell raised no okay so
other foreign affairs related questions
for peter
um
tanya you had asked for the floor before
so i gave you back the floor so i give
you back the floor uh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign affairs
yes absolutely foreign affairs
i have another
package of questions for on migration
but i will first ask about turkey
and as you know the committee of
ministers of the council of europe
decided to launch in prison proceedings
against turkey due to its refusal to
implement the judgement on of the
european court of human rights and
immediately released osman cavalla
i saw the announcements yesterday by
peter and taas
but i would like to know if this changes
anything for turkey's european
perspective
thank you very much peter
thank you thank you maria well the
statement yesterday was very clear i
mean we reacted to the launching on
infringement procedures so we will need
to wait until the end of the
procedure and the results of the
procedure but in general we've been very
clear on the case of mr cavalla we have
repeatedly called for his release we
have repeatedly called for uh respecting
the decisions by the european court of
human rights in his case
and we repeatedly stressed our concerns
when it comes to independence of
judiciary in turkey and to the adherence
of turkish judiciary system to
international and european norms so of
course judiciary and independence of
judiciary and adherence of turkish
judiciary to european standards is being
considered in uh in the in the process
of fulfilling the necessary criteria in
order to move in the accession process
on which anna can give you more details
you know that the member states are
regularly reviewing everything turkey
does when it comes to to it's a bid to
move forward on the european road and
these are all um elements that fit into
this review that is being then done by
the member states uh and
which then uh as a consequence consider
whether to whether to proceed with
turkey further on its european path or
not
maria do you have a follow-up question
on this i see you still have your hand
raised no
yes yes yes can you hear me yes i have a
follow-up
since we are speaking about turkey again
um i would like to know what is the
state of play about the options paper on
varus any news from this round
thank you
well as always with options papers these
are products for the member states who
are discussing the who are discussing
them and these discussions are ongoing
and if there will be any results to be
announced it will be announced properly
as always
thank you any other foreign relations
related questions hanzo
and so we make sure you have the right
source and press speak
yeah go ahead
speak speaker's pressed
you're on a train okay
my question is
my in the train yes
my question is concerning the french
president's
talks with moscow
to what extent are have they been
coordinated
with
external affairs
and the second question is
there are news in german german news
channels concerning
mr stottenburg that the nato general
secretary is going to have another
office
in a back
for
his country
has that been um
has the european union being on informed
since we uh we always portray that the
nato eu relations have improved over the
time thank you very much and have a nice
weekend
um okay let's answer first your your
question on the on the call of president
macron with
with president putin
peter
indeed i mean this was already i mean
french president macron had the number
of calls with president putin by now and
all the calls are taking place in the
context of what the eu is doing in terms
of engaging both with russia and with
other partners
with the ultimate aim and objective to
bring russia to the escalation of the
current situation around ukraine so of
course the messaging is coordinated
president macron delivers european
messages as they have been agreed among
the european allies together with the
partners from the nato from the united
states and they are part of the broad
outreach that the eu is doing in the
current context of the crisis
on your second question honestly we have
no comment it is definitely not for us
to comment on
announcements on
positions to be held by
holders of positions in other
international
organizations there is definitely as you
have seen very close coordination
between
the commission
the ais and
nato
on policy
we have seen it in various contexts in
particular in the context of the
tensions
with belarus and now
with russia on the situation in
in ukraine
okay are there other questions
for us on foreign affairs
no then uh we move on to other issues
and i had a nikolai who had raised his
hand early on nicola go ahead
but
yeah
yes nikolai nielsen e observer i'm
keeping my camera turned off because of
internet issues but i had a
question on frontex
yesterday commissioner johansen floated
the idea
of creating a political management board
for the agency and i just had three
questions on that
will this board also conduct oversight
of the agency
did her idea receive any support among
the ministers
and when does she want this board up and
running
thank you
anita
anything that we can add to the to the
commissioner's comments
but um
without wanting to
uh prejudge what they will say you know
when you have such uh announcements we
usually then
then work on the on the proposals
so you need to have a bit of patience
when it comes to the details but anita
is there anything that you can add
thank you very much nikolai uh yes we
have seen this and i will need to follow
up with you bilaterally on on the exact
details
and
explanations
okay any other questions on home affairs
issues for anita today
maria
yes thank you again for the floor so i
would like to ask for the 19 migrants
who died on wednesday in turkey near the
border with greece
i heard yesterday commissioner johansson
saying that the greek minister didn't
provide any information
do you have any news from the greek
authorities on that
anita um as mentioned also yesterday by
commissioner johansson it is very
important that we establish the facts
and um this is a matter for the national
authorities to
investigate
we'll also be asking frontex and europa
on this matter for any information they
might um have
and um indeed as also mentioned
yesterday uh in the midday um the
commissioner has been in close contact
also with the greek
authorities to find out more but at this
stage it is still too early to give you
any um full update on this matter so
facts still need to be established
information still needs to be gathered
maria you have a follow-up
yes sorry
turkey is blaming greece for another
pushback do you have the same concerns
do you have any indication that this was
the case anything from this
point of view thank you
anytime
first and foremost the commission is
always concerned concerned about
pushbacks and we take this
reporting very very seriously
and
of course it is important that we speak
with all actors um yesterday in lille
and the day before
the commissioner took advantage of the
presence of the greek authorities to
speak but equally of course will also be
in touch with the turkish authorities on
on these matters
thank you
um i don't know if you mentioned the
fact that we were also um asking frontex
and europol for uh information on this i
think it's important to
uh to mention it if it slipped my mind
right
any other questions on home affairs for
anita
that is not the case
thank you anita
oliver
hi um i don't know who's in charge of
that but i'd like to know what's the
state of play of the um due diligence
uh act or due diligence legal proposal
uh the commission from
president uh promised at her state of
the union
um
speech last september half a year ago
almost half a year so the whole uh
forced labor
standards thing
oliva
i invite you to have a look at the lisa
des points review which as you know we
publish
and which gives you an indication of
points which
have
tentatively been uh programmed for
discussion or and adoption
in um in college uh we're not in the
habit of
giving a step-by-step account of
preparations on um on proposals while
services are working on them the least
point preview is your best indication of
progress being made on a on a proposal
oliver you have a follow-up
yes thank you sorry i don't have the
list uh in front of me is is it in there
and can we trust on it being um you know
proposed at such date thank you look
oliva you'll excuse me for not having
every single point which is on the lpp
from now until july at the top of my
head
there are dozens of proposals which are
there so i'd invite you to
have a look and we can always discuss
bilaterally
if you have any doubts as to whether it
is there or not because of a name issue
or or whatever
oliva
yes thank you i mean i understand
there's there's lots on your plate
however the president uh raised this
issue very prominently in his speech he
said now i quote human rights are not
for sale there are let me have a look 25
million
people out there who are threatened or
coerced into forced labor we can never
accept that they are forced to make
products and these products end up for
sale at shops here in the eu i mean i'm
just saying uh
uh this is not any of these other dozens
of uh proposals that might be more
technical or a bit more let's put that
way
uh you know
politically
irrelevant thing
well the more politically relevant an
issue is
oliver the more it needs to be prepared
uh well
thoroughly in order to make sure that it
meets the high standards that you would
expect on your side
of such a proposal so
the fact that a proposal comes early
does not mean that it is more important
than a file that comes late that i think
is a point which uh we would all uh do
well to remember
in all circumstances the second thing is
that i would say that there were many
important proposals that the president
announced in her state of union speech
some have already come others will come
and we're in administration with the
resources we have dealing with multiple
crises at the same time and therefore as
i'm sure you can understand it takes a
bit of time before proposals are worked
through and make it to the college
right that being said um let us now move
to other issues and i give the floor to
joanna
you hear me
go ahead
go ahead okay jonas
for mlx uh i have a trade question
again about the u.s deal so probably for
miriam
do you have any estimations uh how much
trade could be untapped by by this deal
and also
why this particular member states spain
and the netherlands
[Music]
will resume uh trade first and which
other countries could follow
suit
thank you
so this is a question for stefan it
seems
thank you very much
i think we'll have to get back to you on
on figures uh in terms of what this
could um make possible in terms of
future trade
as far as as the countries are concerned
um that i've mentioned uh discussions
have been ongoing between the fda and
between from on the united states side
and the european commission
with regard to the different production
systems to come to these bivalve
mollusks and for instance audits have
been performed in the netherlands and in
spain by american authorities and vice
versa audits have also been performed by
the commission in massachusetts and in
washington state on the basis of these
audits on the base of further
discussions
uh it was decided by both sides that the
production systems of um
used in these countries
required or could use a mutual
recognition it's on the base of this
mutual recognition that was then decided
to open the market for trade with
these countries
as far as other member states are
concerned i'm not in a position to say
anything at this stage
as i explained before other member
states from the european union
could also be allowed to export their
bivalve mollusks to the united states
following a simplified authorization
procedure but i am not in a position to
tell you now
when for which member states this may be
the case thank you
thank you very much
are there other questions
on this issue
for stefan
no so i go to naomi
hi eric thanks very much for taking my
question you know mirror irish times um
it's an hr question
and it's about whether you have any
comment in the light of there was a
ruling
in a
case yesterday where a judge dismissed
all charges uh taken against people in
relation to the golf gate controversy
which was the genesis of why the former
commissioner phil hogan ended up losing
his job i was just wondering in given
that all these criminal charges have
been dropped and the judge has said that
there was nothing against the law that
was done
and it was noted that it was a pity that
people had lost their jobs over it i was
wondering if the commission has any
regrets um over not sort of fighting to
keep uh commissioner hogan at the time
thank you
thank you naomi we never comment uh
decisions uh by national courts
the statements that
we made at the time of the events
and the departure of commissioner hogan
stand
and we have nothing to add to what we
said at the time
george
yes hi thanks for the giving the floor
uh apologies for the uh camera uh the
question is on travel arrangements and
uh and the rules on uh tests etc i
understand from the new rules that con
member states are not supposed to ask
for additional pcrs uh before or after
arrival
uh on the holders of the the vaccine
certificate uh but i understand also
that some countries still do at least
separate us from what i've seen
could we have some qualifications on
what is
mandatory for the member states on this
issue and when are we expected to
see member states
uniformly
stop requiring pcr tests for travelers
that have the certificate thank you
this is a question that we've answered
many times but i give the floor to
christian once again on this
yes thank you thank you georges for your
question happy to
uh to clarify once more
um indeed the
ss was
reconfirmed
in the adoption of the recent
recommendation
by the member states on free movement
the the eu digital corporate certificate
should in principle
be enough for
for
travel within the european union
and the principle no additional
restrictions
should be
imposed
um of course there are
you know there have been certain
exemptions particularly in the in the
at the height of the omicron wave
uh where we are
by the way now seeing i would say a
trend towards torch easing these
restrictions or lifting these
restrictions in the number in the number
of member states in the in the last few
days thinking of denmark and also
announcements from portugal yesterday
um
so this is this is the principle that
that you correctly that you correctly
noted
and as we have also said in as actually
we have said in the statement by the
responsible
uh commissioners on the day of the
adoption of this recommendation we would
expect member states to now go back
to
the agreed rules and and um to
to to lift the remaining restrictions in
this context
thank you any other questions on this
issue george you have a follow-up
yes just a clarification is there a sort
of deadline for when member states are
supposed to lift these additional
measures thank you
christian
well there is there is no particular
deadline but um
in the
most of these these restrictions that
have been notified to us because there
is no notification
um application under the individual code
certificate regulation
we had a number of member states where
already these restrictions have
well
only ran until the end of january we are
in contact with some of the member
states to make sure and clarify whether
indeed these recommendations have have
also officially expired
and there are some others where it is
foreseen to expire
in early february
so this is the situation where we stand
at the moment of and of course you
continue to follow this closely and also
to follow up with member states where it
is not entirely clear whether the
recommendations are still in place or
not
okay any other questions on
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
community
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
b
[Music]
foreign